[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay this one oh wow I'm tall foot once
in my life
hello let's get the chat so you see what
you're saying this be good haven't done
I lied she might this is a long time by
the way I've been ill with this really
cold like bad cold flu thing that's
being run around in England at least
apparently it's like some bad flu that's
that's come over here up inhale since
New Year's Eve how much does that suck
but hi so today's gonna be a really
short stream I just figured I've got an
old version of the sérgio game that I'm
helping to make this year for my third
year of university so I just figured I
should show you what I've been doing by
the way this yeah it'sit's here this
green box is for any of you who do the
whole like super chat thing or any new
subscribers so I don't miss you and you
like pop up with your names and stuff
and I'm like ah but it's in the way of
my cooler ass poster when I got a
fallout poster I've wanted one for so
long and then my friend got your on for
Christmas and I was like how did you
know what she was like I didn't know I
just thought you'd like you'd like the
game and I was like lately I've been
looking for one forever
because I just loved the art style and
fallout but anyway hey hey hey hey hey
tree cat hey biospark dreamer hey Mac oh
hey Kai hey ed
hey Alex I like how you guys are so
confused Aaron if you were like is she
playing oh she's sick no that's my
soundcloud actually I'm been able to
singing so long it sucks old back so I
went to the studio and everything and I
was like I can't sing because I've been
coughing but I feel so much better than
I did last week which is good and I'm
just been drinking all these like
horrible teas hoping to get better
Oh Ashley I have a horrible pill but I
should probably take that all together
holding them Barret guys all the organic
stuff is weird
how have you been hope you're doing well
hey know me hey Jonas Jonasson Jonas
sure hey Jonathan hey silver shadow I
don't know why I'm having troubles it's
people's names seems people's names okay
usually there's a game tied behind I'm
always so scared to show you my stuff
especially now because it looks like
balls cuz it really does I haven't
really like thought about the way it
looks or anything yet cuz right now it
was just like get the functionality down
I'm not sure how much to explain to you
about this game I mean have a look to
have any we've got concept art so
basically for those of you who didn't
know I'm the game designer for this game
a game designer or someone that comes up
with a narrative about the reason behind
things they do the game design document
which is a pain it's like 20 pages of
just technical and narrative I like now
to stuff but the technical stuff is just
like oh my god specs and stuff
everywhere anyway um and they also do
the code and they manage the team
really like fine it's so difficult to
make schedules for everything but yeah
so and then I'm working with two
wonderful guerrillas who do the modeling
because like yeah I just I don't
understand my thing I don't really enjoy
it as much but yeah okay
so this is let's get up this little
piece of concept art so you can have a
little lip got hair on my face
perfection what is happening outside can
you hear it
what they're doing out there right why
are you opening like that
where did you go uh-huh
my unity game is gone there it is sorry
this isn't mean things going on like her
I just hope bear with me one sight wait
come over here my poor little computer
is already dying with all this stuff
it's like what are you doing to me oh
yeah I'm saving up for a new laptop as
well which is exciting so uh yeah this
is the little piece of concepts part I
want like posters around the environment
basically the main concept is about
perfection and it all adds I got it from
a night in the summer where I literally
could not sleep and I don't know I was
just thinking about being perfect I
don't know who spend the whole night
like just being annoyed because I wasn't
perfect I'm wondering how I could be
perfect and then I was like going on
this rant in my head like what is
perfect perfect is subjective it's
basically what I made that video about
and then I was like hmm but then what
would happen if someone had advanced
technology so much that they could
actually make a piece of technology that
would make you perfect and by perfect it
would be so say if you wanted to become
like a perfect chef or a perfect coder
or perfect anything you would kind of
code this well put it on this headset
tell it what you wanted from the headset
and the headset would kind of take out
everything within your head that
procrastinated that didn't lead toward
your desired goal and kept it in the
headset but then if you think about it
that's pretty much your personality like
it's taking away parts of yourself
that you thought didn't make you perfect
but actually made you you and then in a
sense it's all a plot by the government
to turn us into mindless robots and so
this is that it's like the initial idea
oh my god are you even still around I I
wouldn't I won't blame you if you've all
gone by now and you're like what the
hell but yeah so that's where it all
came from and then I was like damn son
this is a good idea for a game because
I've always had this thought in my head
oh look it's my playstation it's
downloading no it's not my TV just
turned off it's blue now but it's
downloading hum event horizon dawn
always an event dawn no whatever
what were they saying yeah yeah so I
love son Hill PT scary games you know I
love scary games and I actually I have
no idea why I start oh yeah no I've been
thinking about this for a long time so
ever since I became a front-end
developer I was seeing things like
interactive HTML videos html5 videos
WebGL videos actually and they use your
login details from social media accounts
to personalize the experience like I
don't know if you've seen it but there's
um a video and interactive video court
take my lollipop I'll just show you it
now why not this has been massive
inspiration for the longest time so I I
came across this when I was working in
London so that was before you knew even
so that was like freaking four years ago
oh my god
so long ago but this shows that you know
the technology is here just no one's
done it yet
why yes so dissertation googling
dissertation I gotta do my dissertation
that was a scary scary thought
take this lollipop yeah so it's a little
hey Tigers like oh hey head man had man
add man hey mister hey James hey Sekulow
hey Jonathan I think my body's in there
for what I need oh don't be
oh my gosh it's gonna work yeah yeah
yeah okay so yeah this is this is what
I've been wanting to make something like
this for the longest time an interactive
video that's personalized to you and
there's even cool ones that I've come
across but I can't find them anymore
it's so annoying
but there was one that used literally
all of your social media accounts like
your G your Google account your Facebook
account your Instagram account each
other who can like everything and the
more that you had online the more
information it could collect from you
and the whole freakin video was
personalized to you it was crazy like
even the audio was one of my youtube
videos playing throughout an audio piece
and then there was like texts coming and
it was all my tweets and I was like what
the hell is so I just thought it was so
interesting that you could not only
personalize an experience to a person
but it's
I'll carry on talking often just watch
this you should all do this afterwards
this is why you just stuck it 83% stop
it
I mean it's a little bit glitchy but
it's still cool
[Music]
it's a little bit glitchy sometimes
using the Facebook SDK doesn't work see
it's my pictures it's specific more
pictures and then it's not coming up
also actually it depends on how secure
your Facebook surf is my facebook kind
of secure I think but some of my friends
weren't when they did this and Lizzie
everything came up and it was
also it shows you it's me he Oh baby me
baby me but yeah like how cool is that
and it yeah it shows you how online hey
cuz I would love to make videos like
this for sure you can't put them on
YouTube platform because YouTube
platform doesn't allow ah no doesn't
share everywhere I'm only gonna be here
for another couple months ah well
crudeness actually I don't even
I should I need to get off this think it
shows you your exact location
oh no okay it glitched out its supposed
to show you your exact location or your
profile picture here bassy is supposed
to be like oh he's come to your house to
find you but yet how freaking cool is
that right so that's something that I
saw years ago and it was massive
inspiration to me so it's just like
that's the coolest thing yeah Friday you
didn't see where I lived anyway oh no
it's lagging [ __ ] god I hate this
internet connection wait maybe it's cuz
downloading the game one sec okay right
I turned off my PlayStation now just in
case that was making it but yeah please
um I've rarely comment like I'm gonna
come and kill yourself like please come
don't come and do that but please check
out that if you want to it's really
really interesting for anyway so that
was like where the idea came from I'm
totally totally rambling now so I was
wondering another another what's the
word and not competition it's a cold
where you challenge yourself another
challenge for myself would be to figure
out if I could do this in a game because
I'm never ready seen a game do this like
they use social media as leaderboards
you know show that like you were better
than your friends or your friends are
better than you but I've never seen a
game actually use you and your personal
information and can you imagine playing
a game
like PT you know that Sun Hills things
not gonna be a thing that's really sad
by the way I'm trying to make a song
about that so that's quite fun but
anyway yeah like imagine walking through
the hallways of PT and then you look on
the side and there's like a little
picture frame and it's you or it's one
of your friends and you're like what why
am I in this game and so yeah this is
why I'm trying to do and it's so funny
because I'm I'm explain to you now and
you're probably thinking like oh gotta
look so cool but now you're actually
gonna see this like it's so this is a a
very oh no it's actually still streaming
yeah is I don't I didn't even know what
the stream health is like it's my
Internet's crash now hey my girl yeah
I'm not sure if the streams okay but I'm
guessing it is cuz it's still streaming
so but anyway this is a very old version
of the game well not that old I guess
but it was when I started to get the
Facebook functionality working because
you can get a lot of information from
Facebook so I'm working with the
Facebook SDK which is made for unity it
was pretty difficult and I'm still kind
of trying to get my head around how I'm
going to demo this on the internet cuz
obviously it needs to be an online game
right because you can make Facebook
games on Android and stuff but I wanted
to make an actual game this time not one
for mobile because then that means that
my teammates have to think about making
things low-poly and making sure it runs
high you know on a mobile device which
it's just a bit more pressure than
making a nice pretty game for PC that
can actually run but this will have to
be streamed online obviously but also
there's more to it just that I wanted to
[ __ ] it in some personality traits as
well so
anyway I've just been trying to do the
code because as long as the code works
then I know I can start making you look
pretty so let me just show you the basic
Facebook functionality what I managed to
get so far I haven't one thing that I
want to get that I haven't
to be fair I haven't even looked into it
it's probably not gonna be that
difficult ways to get a Facebook friends
name this is a gray box so this is what
it looks like with no furniture and no
text yes it's very simple but basically
it's supposed to be like obviously you
have this perfection headset and you're
going into kind of like a futuristic
therapy slash Hospital thing it's gonna
be very bioshock asks so postmodern and
whatnot and you got to this little kiosk
and you got to sign in and there's like
C press e to introverts oh how amazing
I've just put this down it's like a
little placeholder in my room but yeah
so this is like the camera angle
switches so you've got a fixed camera
angle you can see the kiosk thing and
then you log in and this obviously won't
happen once it's online once it's online
that login button prompts where there's
facebook pop-ups it's like this wants to
use your facebook details do you give it
permission and then you say yes but
because this is obviously being run
through Facebook I've got to put in my
access token I don't know if anything
will happen if you see this at first oh
look here's the code I'll go through
that with you in a second
I don't know if anything you'll happen
if you see my my access code but just in
case we won't let you see it okay so
send success ooh
success give it a second so then it
changes to different view and it pulls
in my facebook profile with my profile
picture my name
and my gender and depending on that
gender it actually switches out the
character that you're playing as I
wonder I think we've just got one in at
the moment but yes so you've got like
your little body thing high body thing
shite where am I I walked through the
wall how do I do that where I am free um
yes so that body will change depending
on whether the text says male or female
and it says male or female from
obviously your Facebook account but if I
just do this again I'll show you some
tongue point through the frickin wall
again please
yeah so let's just pay in that same
access tokens good yeah sweet so that's
now stored the information and then so
usually I mean I was like looking into
this and there was a lot of difficult
things and it was all like oh yeah you
have to store it in the backend and do
this and I was like damn I'm not that
good at back-end developer but it's okay
because I don't load any new levels or
anything so all I have to do is just get
that information there and then put it
into this scripts that its Reverend wet
a little relevant to so as you can see
if I had my profile picture and then
this is just for me to check out my code
with but look I'm ball press e to
interrupts and then I'm a little ball
ball
can I see me can you show me me on the
ball I love it
but yeah so obviously that's not gonna
be a part of the game I don't know maybe
it will be Easter egg my face and you'll
face it on your face and a ball won't
even be my face for your face on a ball
maybe I can put all of our faces on
balls be like the ballroom
but yeah and there's also scripts that
are like supposed to keep banging things
supposed to have a look at like how you
interrupt the things I don't know how I
do that
how are you interact with the game while
you're playing it so there's gonna be
loads of items that you can like pick up
just like that ball that balls not gonna
be that but it's gonna be items like
that and the more that you look at it
the more observant you are and then yeah
you can peek through this so basically
on here it's gonna have a little text
bar and it will say your friend's name
so as soon as I log in or you live in to
Facebook it's gonna find a random friend
name she can find out random friend
information how weird is that
and yeah I'm gonna put that text onto
there yeah get me out I literally just
move this from PC to Mac so there's been
so many problems big paused in play mode
yeah but there you go thank you because
I don't know whenever you import
anything from a PC to a Mac I always
goes wrong or vice versa this is the
room where you put on the headset and
right now this is the headset and then
you put it on is Xiao Yi I don't know
one of the two come on interact do you
interact with the headset you're
annoying me
why are you doing anything
basically once you put this on
everything's supposed to change but I'm
not interacting with it for some reason
why not see what my console.log says
this is what coding is all of us just
like why isn't that working let's have a
look
headset on equals true okay so I just
hadn't put the I hadn't put the relevant
script on so basically I've got a script
that changes the material that is put
onto all the stuff in that game this is
really difficult to explain because once
you put the headset on
it's supposed to turn to our game so
it's supposed to be like kind of a nice
cozy atmosphere then you walk into and
you're like oh look it's my friend's
name on this door what are they doing in
there you peep through if you want to if
you don't peep through it's okay if you
peek through though I wanted to bring
you back to like old horror games so if
you do peek through and you know you did
that thing you look through the door and
then you went back out of that once you
put the headset on and the world changes
the materials change everything goes a
bit dark and gloomy very much think
Silent Hill very much Silent Hill I love
Sam hell we want oil of Sam Hill you go
back and the door that you did peep into
the camera and god shifts and they are
looking at you in essence I think I've
actually got this already in play but
you know you gotta start somewhere and I
think as long as you get the
functionality done then everything else
like the look of things whatever there's
some other ideas for the for the looks I
want to have real photographs there's
nothing that actually my lecturer said
which was that when you're going through
these hallways it should get
progressively more spooky so I was
thinking like evil
within style I'm gonna put hidden Pillai
ders at the end of the hallway so when
you go into them collide is alike
well boxes that just trigger when you
enter them but you don't actually see
them in the game world so when you enter
them I'm just going to instantiate my
position to be back at the start of the
hallway
so it will be very much like evil within
where you think you've gone to the end
of the hallway but you haven't like
you're back at the start again and when
that happens I'll change the hallways
materials again so they just get like
progressively more creepy and I was
thinking of just having things like I
want to have photography real
photography so I'm gonna go out and take
pictures of my friends and it's gonna be
close-ups of skin and stuff like that
and the beginning of the game it's like
all nice and they've got perfect skin
and whatever by the end of the game
after they put on the perfection headset
their skins all bloody and gross and so
yeah that's a thing but anyway I just
looked through the people walk walk walk
walk walk to the laboratory and you
won't be walking this fast e this is for
demo purposes right so I think I've done
this now I don't know I'm guessing so
and then so if you go back here there is
a hidden collider here yeah hey hey
character artist she just made this one
for me for demo purposes the little body
so I could animate here and like stuff
but basically she's gonna have a male
and female body and that's it so like
it's watching you as soon as you go back
out of it again the collider is
destroyed so you can't make that happen
again so it's like you lost control of
the camera for a bit because I was
looking a line to how to make people
scared and losing controllers is one
major part of fear fear um I don't know
do you wanna look at the code I didn't
really know how to go I can go through
the code with you it's okay okay the
live stream health is good which is good
yasmin balls Easter Egg
we were talking about the balls that was
so far ago far ago long ago how many
hours have you spent and have you left
on this project I don't know about hours
but we've been working on this since his
start the year yes I know it doesn't
seem like very much but that's I mean
you've got to remember that's like
concept in stage we've made a storyboard
we've made like I said like pretty much
it was a 1520 page game design document
schedule's the guys are still modeling
we've made new balls concepts art like
there's a lot that you have to do in a
game yes and there will be a monster as
well actually mr. T Layton so Tabitha
character artist is making a monster but
it's going to be one that's kind of
think of Pyramid Head right Oh sound
level again um where when you first see
him in the school is it in school in the
hospital was in the hospital but anyway
when you first see him it's not actually
like trying to kill you he's just
staring at you like through bars and
stuff that's what it's gonna be like a
little monster yeah yeah new cuz this is
for University hey shebang it'll be fun
if she was the monster more like if I
was the monster she just seems like you
should where'd you just have like a
floating Yard Man ball just like chasey
after you that would be freaking
terrifying but yeah let's have a look at
why what I've got here so I don't know
why I'm so weird I think it's because
I'm just like turn ill and I'm scared
I'm not like it's so scares me sharing
all this stuff with you because I know
it doesn't look that great at the moment
but hopefully as well because I know my
last game though I made not all of you
to play it because it was and
but it's not even all Android friends
it's just some of them so I know you can
play this but hopefully you can play
this game so anyway this is the Facebook
blog in code I didn't realize that
opened this up oh yeah no I did open it
up why is it all red so yeah this is all
the SDK code which actually I had to
like learn alone because none of our
lecturers had ever used the Facebook SDK
actually I mean it was kind of annoying
because ah lecture I thought this was an
illegal idea which was kind of funny but
obvious it's not legal as long as you
ask for permission you have the pop-up
and stuff like it's totally cool yes so
this is how I get the picture you get
the picture callback and that's it you
let you have a link of like me picture
and obviously me is whoever is logged in
and yeah so that's what happens if
Facebook is logged in did you do that's
all about switching the camera view
because usually noticed it went from
first person to a fixed camera angle
over the little boxy thing I can't think
of words kiosk that's what I call it
kiosk and then what I do is when I get
that I graph results which is the
picture I turn it into a 2d texture and
then you can get whatever component you
want renderer so it's on the cube is on
a cute it's not on a cube what you want
about it's not a cube it's not a ball
but I I've probably made the ball a cube
weight you boys a queue up here yeah
I've just got as a game object so
probably just mine put it on the cube on
the ball but it's called a cube here
sorry to confuse you but yeah I just get
the component renderer which handles the
material and then I make the material
the image see there see it's a texture
2d
called image and it equals the result
texture which is yeah yeah
making sense think so don't know yeah so
loads in UI logs in the UI dock
transform dot find profile pic getting
the image turning it into a sprite yeah
I wrote this before Christmas so I'm
kind of reminding myself how I did it as
well but yeah and there's one more thing
I need to do which no two more things
actually we just find the random name
there's a really good well I mean the
SDK is actually there's loads of
information on that online but there's a
really good page where it tells you
exactly what kind of invasion you can
pull in with what sort of missions so
that's been a very helpful you can just
search that online if you want to but
basically here so this is like it checks
the gendered gender text because there's
a text field that gets that gets filled
in when you log in I think it's this one
yeah gender callback yeah and then so it
finds the gender text fields and then
gets the text component and then fills
the text with gender plus the profile
gender that Facebook has provided you
so that's male or female only thing is I
don't know how to make it come with a
capital letter at the start which is
weird but yeah so what it does is it
checks if that gender text field
contains either female or male and you
need to make sure that it's spelled
exactly the same that's what it would be
spelled so because I can't put a capital
letter at the beginning because it's
taking it from the Facebook information
I need to keep it all lowercase
and after that I can do with it whatever
I want so it's constantly checking
whether it's saying female or male if
it's saying nothing it won't do anything
if it's saying female then I'm gonna set
active true on the female body what I do
is I've got my camera here where's my
lil you see here I'm totally rambling I
don't think I'm very good at explaining
this kind of stuff but I try here's my
first-person controller somewhere there
you are so I've got gonna make you
bigger so they can see come on be fair
be fair
let them see go go away so this is the
player and it's basically just like a
first-person camera attached to a 3d
model that I then put some different
animation States on that change
depending on like how you're walking how
fast you're working and things like that
so in here if I open this up it's got
the female right now so I need to add
the male as well so and then it's got so
this is all the model and yeah so that's
got a rig in it as well so that helps
with the animations and then I'll put
exactly the same but I call it male and
at the very beginning of the game to
stop any confusion I'm gonna have an
animation of the walking towards the
kiosk and then just start the game with
you having to log in because obviously
you can't look down and not see your
body because that's not very immersive
and I don't want you to look down and
see a boy's body if you're a girl or a
girl's body if you're a boy because the
whole point in this game is that
supposed to try and immerse you into the
game as much as possible by using a
social media information and everything
else so yeah what it will do is it would
check the gender text fields and then
I'll have I'll declare to game
and I will make one female one male and
get both models and then for the the
code I would just do set active true or
set active false so at the beginning I'm
guessing they're both gonna be set
active false but if the gender text dot
X contains female then the female game
object will set up to true I think that
makes sense yes
how many annoying unity bugs have you
run into so far says odd bug I mean all
the time it just happens on a daily
basis right like I came back to uni we
started again on Monday and I spent like
20 minutes wondering why because this is
an old version that I've just opened up
in my Mac so it's not like the most
up-to-date one but I was putting lights
and things like that into the
environment and I don't know why but
this one light just was not working so I
changed everything I changed the way
that I had I changed the properties on
the environment
I changed the lighting settings in unity
I was looking around online like why is
that my point like working the most
basic thing and then I just decided
after 20-25 minutes of Dawson around
she's just put in another light and it
worked fine it was just that I don't
know why but it's just that one light so
yeah there's a lot of weird bugs in
unity and I think actually one of the
major things that I'm having problems
with I'm I'm just not gonna worry about
now I'm just gonna think about
everything else in the game is that she
the Facebook SDK because sometimes in
uni the internet isn't that good because
I guess everyone's on it and then the
Facebook functionality doesn't work so a
lot of the time it wasn't pulling in my
puts my profile picture and then I I
remember one day I lit she spent I think
half day
day trying to sort it out turns out my
Cove was perfectly fine if it's just for
some reason not connecting to the
internet properly so that was so
annoying but yeah now I'm just gonna
gonna focus on everything else I want to
put some particles in it I'm probably
gonna gonna recycle some bits from the
last game where I made particle systems
and flickering lights and stuff like
that but I mean if you've already made
it why not why not use it again and I
need I need to throw out the audio I
think audio is gonna be vital in this
game so I might be cheeky and ask my
producer if he wants to write some audio
because I'm going back to the studio
this Saturday anyway so and and yeah the
Facebook things I'm super cool but also
I want to do more than just that I want
to do personality traits as well so I've
got my scripts in here to do a
personality data so yeah there's not
much in here at the moment but ah so at
the moment this is checking to see
whether you peeked into that room with
your friend's name on it and also
whether you've got the head so on but I
also want it to have these integers and
that's what they're called right and
keep tally I guess of all these
different scores that you can get by the
end of the game I don't know whether I
should tell you that I want your player
not realize I want the whole point of
the game to be that you don't realize
you're being judged
just like in Oh guess what I'm gonna say
Sam Hill to where you're playing
um obviously played throughout the whole
game and you don't realize that the more
that you look at the letter for Mary the
more actually changes the ending of the
game it's actually judging you on your
actions throughout that whole game and
it's not just about Mary it's like other
things as well I thought that was
amazing
because in games nowadays like your
telltale games and you know life is
stranger stuff at that it's cool but you
know you're being judged you know that
there's a decision to be made
you know that it's gonna impact the
ending but when you play a game you
don't even realize that it's judging you
on how you're playing the game you're
literally just doing what you want to do
you're not even second-guessing yeah
you're I guess it's the it's the closest
thing to being truly you cuz you don't
realize that you being judged just like
in the real world I guess
but anyway so yeah it's got this
observant so that's gonna be how many
times you pick up objects cuz obviously
if you can see oh yeah I want to do like
amnesia so when you scroll over and
interactable
item a little like pointer or hand or
something comes up just that you do you
can interact with it
patients what was that oh yeah I don't
know I haven't like think of extra
narrative points just just to fit these
kind of data but intrusive nuts it's
gonna be whether you peeped in on your
friend or not bravery is a little part
on the end
oh yeah patience was also gonna be how
quickly you can go through the game
because you can go through very quickly
it's gonna be a demo so I'm gonna be a
full game obviously but yeah I'm kind of
excited so I've already got the
observing thing thing working so I think
it will show in console so if you know
don't go full screen you're gonna go
full screen aren't you yeah I know
Weetabix like not everyone is gonna be
up sensitive or what they actually like
but do you I mean like it's the closest
thing to what you might be like I know
everyone messes around the game whatever
but it's still you and what you wanted
to do because you don't know that you're
being judged and I think am I making
sense I think I'm making sense I don't
know but yeah if you know you're being
judged you you're gonna try and make the
best decision but if you don't you're
just gonna do all that whatever the hell
you want you know where does
say it's over here isn't it
yeah don't maximize on plate please
thank you you
yeah so if you look down here Facebook
has been initialized brilliant behavior
may not be the same when used in iOS
it's okay I'm not using an IRS whoo
there you go see
picked up item observance e1 yes soon
and I think I think is the same if you
pick it up again
wow this lag observance e2 perfect so
you see little things like that and then
at the end of the game you get you get a
little kind of score thing of your
personality traits where based on the
game and because I'm using face because
okay why not share it with you buddies
so yeah I'll put like a little share
thing because everyone knows this
personality test everyone's like oh what
am I like hey Diego movies
boop boop boop boop boop boop boop but
yeah so that's pretty much that
I'll probably show it to you again when
there's more to see more to look at but
I'm pretty happy with the functionality
and I'm just pretty happy with the
overall idea I'd love to see big games
play with this I understand why they
don't because the Facebook SDK and stuff
it's it's not the most reliable thing to
work with but I just think there's so
much potential not just to use social
media for sharing but to help immerse
you into into a new world I think so
this is my take on the idea this is just
my little you know peek into the world
because my my lecturer was kind of like
try not to make this too gimmicky
and I do see what he means but in a way
I don't really mind because I think it's
unique and it shows initiative and I'd
rather try it and then realize that it
doesn't work but at least have something
to show for it which is why I'm doing
the personality traits as well not just
focusing on the Facebook but um but yeah
so that's that's the thing
sorry this wasn't massively entertaining
I never really exactly know how to
explain all of this but yeah I'm excited
and I wanted to share it with you all I
also wanted to depending on the gender
change different parts the game because
in one of the games after you put the
headset on to make you feel Wow
a bit scared like it like I said it's
supposed to be a horror game so I was
kind of kind of put graffiti on the
walls or assets on the ground that would
be relevant to each gender so I was
thinking for a girl that could be goofy
t saying things like [ __ ] just like a
word that all girls probably would get
triggered by but I'm finding it
difficult to think about stuff like that
for guys I guess because I'm not guys so
I don't really know but all I can think
of is maybe like man up or something
like that so if there's anything you can
think of do let me know if there's kind
of a word that you think is universally
triggering or just you know kind of
difficult for guys then do let me know
cuz all I think of us man up maybe [ __ ]
you know just guys men don't cry I don't
know something like that
hey life time an adventure I'm glad you
like it shopping the loony when did you
get into coding and when did you decide
you wanted to make video games so I did
a college course back back a long time
ago I was young then I did a media
course and as part of the media course I
don't even know how I've just always
been like very intrigued by education
and I realized that gaming was like
another course run
never under the same bracket of colleges
and I was like hey how come games aren't
part of the media because they are and
then my my lecturer was so good and I
was getting I I got top marks in my
media then again she got top marks in my
hip media college course I did I was
getting 100% in everything because I
loved it and it was such a good course
as well you did a bit of everything so
you did like a bit of web design you bit
did some filmmaking you did some radio
and I just said I want to do some games
and they were like well you know you've
been exceeding so why not do an extra
unit and they sent me off to another
college and then I had to do six months
work in eight weeks and I did it and it
was so fun because I was up until like
3:00 a.m. on my computer at home just
teaching myself how to make a gaming
unity and it was so much fun and then I
made the game at the end of those eight
weeks and it was based on Maze Runner I
think I've actually done a video on it
yeah and yeah I just freaking loved it
and then my college she she was like
you're gonna go uni and I was like no I
don't really know what I want to do in
uni because I didn't know where the one
to do film or games and then he was like
why don't you just move to London and I
was like okay I don't know my life is
weird I just I don't think things
through I just do them so I moved from
my little seaside town to London and
became a web developer this is very
strange
and that's how I probably going to
coding because I kind of had to black my
way I was like yeah I can code I know
JavaScript and then I had to go and
teach myself JavaScript off codecademy
and then after working there for two
years I was like I'm done with this web
development life I want to actually make
games son I went to uni and that's my
story
yeah why my disappointment that's
I'm sure I missed I missed something I
think it's a really cool concept Thank
You Magdalene justice I'm glad you think
so
her new car saw the video of my Maze
Runner a game yeah it was interesting to
say the least to say the least
and Michael likes the fullscreen I don't
know my wife comes a bit crappy so I
apologize for that I need to get proper
streaming stuff but for that I think I
need a PC or something once I've been
leaving my hair to go natural recently
it's just like it's always in between
just frozen Carol's I'm like what are
you doing you can't you do you hurt you
do you but good news I did bye is it
horizon event dawn I always get confused
I always think it's called event horizon
that is a film and a good film though I
haven't seen that film in forever
but anyway I have downloaded that one I
was downloading I need to download it
still cuz I stopped it for this dream
but yeah it went from like three hours
to four hours to five hours through oh
yeah the way I'm playing this game
tonight so I'm gonna save that till next
week have waste you want more games
coming out I don't really know what to
play this it's coming out soon
I mean I'm probably gonna go because I
meant for a guy I would say you're a
disappointment
ah Mustafa I think that's that's true
for boys and girls for that is that is a
good no one likes to be called a
disappointment yes
oh I wish I had more time for this ah
yeah horizon zero dawn that's the one
Michael thank you thank you for five
euros well I appreciate it
we're pretty doki-doki did you club no
oh oh where is it where was I look he's
so cute why why is he tiny like why is
he
wait where's the little zombie thing he
wasn't in the all the screen but Michael
was at all there was a little like
running zombie that was him then we play
again so you can see it if I can get it
up again
do living didn't enter him how do I do
it again I don't know I can test it down
there you go John
that's not real like what
hey your muffin I'm just about to finish
the stream now but I'll be back next
week and Dimitri as well it's free on
Steam I can't play games on Steam and
this is like a really like easy to play
game but even when I put binding of
issac on Steam my Mac is like it just
can't it can't handle anything it can
hardly even handle me showing you my
little crappy game on unity so yeah it's
not the best no I haven't played
undertale but i don't see any point in
playing undertale now so you know it all
I think undertale was a really cool game
but I know it so this is one thing I
find kind of annoying about YouTube ok
wanna watch these games with them as
soon as I've watched them especially
when they're very narrative ly driven
like undertale you just you don't need
to play them anymore cuz you've already
watched them say yeah it's annoying no
play it but I think I'm really at bored
because I literally know everything I
mean you know the whole point of a game
was that you would play it and not
realize how the ending was about to
change
but I know it wrong so me play for
yourself maybe like maybe I will wait a
year or so like maybe when I've kind of
forgotten it yeah
so what saying that she see my friends
the other day I miss playing games just
for me like no I love playing games for
you guys but I do kind of miss just like
manga now I know you guys do it too you
know when you play games and you just
talk mom out you just like oh yeah it's
totally how I play games but you know
when I'm with you guys I'm looking at
the chat and stuff I've got to be very
proactive but yeah it's just nice and
posed to be like totally just in stock
stir in sucked in but I can't play
horror games on my own so that's why I
stream them with you guys cuz I'm like
oh it's too scary so yeah I do that
instead um
cuphead cuphead I've heard a cop had
cuphead isn't it like kind of a dark I
to knee style oh yeah oh well Disney
damn I need to get homesick tight
looks like the old world Disney games
with evil flowers
anyway I'm a goal thanks for coming I
hope you like the game so far I know
there's not that much to show but I hope
it shows I hope
the effort that I've put into the code
shows at least because even just that
whole sequence of changing the camera
angles when you're peeping in and when
it changes and then it checks to see
whether you've peeped in and then checks
oh my gosh it just took forever so I
hope I hope it's shown but I am I am
excited to get back into it to make you
look pretty now and just yeah just turn
it into something I'm just I'm just
excited to share with you because I know
a lot of you couldn't play my last game
and I think you'll be good if you guys
play it so if you want to see more of
this and how it progresses do let me
know in the comments below do check out
gaming with you add my next my second
channel where I will be trying my
hardest to upload more content on there
about the game I'm just I don't know I
just feel like I'm not professional
enough to make tutorials and it is
difficult when you're making this new
doing so much work to find time to get
everyone to sit down and talk about what
you're doing it's actually a lot harder
in theory that I thought it was gonna be
but I'm trying so yeah and there will be
another video next Monday so don't worry
I'll be back very soon like within a
week so you'll see me and next week I'll
be playing horizon zero dawn that's the
one not a very over izing event I might
watch event horizon now I think about it
oh wait oh just watch another episode of
back mirror I watched the first first
episode the other day it's pretty
interesting I always I always do this
but now I always feel guilty for the
characters that end up being weird I'm
always like not guilty but I feel like I
feel like although I misunderstood bless
them and then they end up being freaks
and I'm like
I'm such a pushover anyway I'll stop
rambling I'll say goodbye to you
individually as I always do he wasn't I
think it was Jefferson who was like I
think you're really cool because you say
because I ask people on Instagram why
why they follow me so I was like shall I
upload more pictures of nature or more
pictures of me and the ukulele or like
what should I do
and then I saw I was asking people why
they followed me and Jefferson was like
you said goodbye to everyone in your
stream and they thought that was really
cool and I was like why do you think you
guys wouldn't notice but anyway so I'm
gonna say goodbye to whoever I can see
I'm sorry if I don't see you but goodbye
mantas goodbye Michael and justice
goodbye I'm speed goodbye Jim hook
goodbye :
goodbye Michael I think I reasoned that
give my yak I'm not bin goodbye Japan
goodbye call until I already say that
your pie left an adventure
goodbye Alex goodbye
I missed a father they already say
goodbye Jim Hawk I don't know if anyone
else I'm scrolling up now to see if I
can see goodbye dear me treat goodbye I
think I think everyone I can see goodbye
Lucas
goodbye Stardust goodbye mark goodbye
Ben
Boop goodbye fritz
so it's Cornelius that's a cool name I
like that one
anyway goodbye everyone thank you bye
everyone in the chat who is making cuz I
know you're here and it's okay I'm not
judging you
because as I say every stream eye-to-eye
my work here so I understand goodbye
Alejandro ah then came in just in time
to see say goodbye to hello and goodbye
but I will see you next week for playing
an actual game I will see you next
Monday where I might as well tell you
it's it's a video of my mum saying the
last hurricane so if you haven't been
able to play the last game that I helped
make then you'll be able to see my mom
play it's quite funny video I'm excited
and I've been I've been editing the
video coming after that for a week now
trying to put some animation in it I'm
not really sure if I even like it but
I'm just gonna put it up anyway it's
very different but you guys like
different so that's okay I'm not
forgetting you Michael and yeah goodbye
Oh who's a coozer I want to say quasar
goodbye Julian you see you put your name
that thank you for putting your name
there yeah see you next week see you on
Monday have a lovely day or evening bye
bye bye